yesterday was the latest incident where
more names landed on the covet 19
reserve list players testing positive uh
and and and all the indications of an
outbreak yeah right and as of late
yesterday morning
you know the browns had closed their
facility
there were at least i think 10 guys now
on the kova 19 reserve list
and it was creating the sense that it
was another baltimore where every day it
was going to be the clarence beaks crop
report who's next how many more how deep
does this go
but the league said on a conference call
yesterday they've determined there isn't
an outbreak that this is just guys
getting it in the community you know
yesterday chris there were eight players
league wide put on the covet 19 reserve
list seven of them were because of
positive tests not close contact so it
gives you an idea
of
the reality that this is unavoidable as
the numbers keep going up and up and up
even though we have gotten numb to it i
saw that the daily deaths in the united
states are up near 4 000 a day i
remember when it was a thousand a day
and we were like holy crap are you
kidding me a thousand people a day are
dying from this and now it's almost four
thousand and i was like
well like what can you do well well what
you can do is all the stuff we should
have been doing all along
and these measures given the extent of
the spread are making it still very very
difficult to avoid the virus as
evidenced by the fact getting more and
more nfl players and the protocols from
the nfl's perspective
stop the virus from moving on to others
in the building right and that's what's
worked for the nfl it has the problem is
you can reach a critical mass of players
who aren't available you can say hey
there's no outbreak all of these guys
are on the covet 19 reserve list are on
for reasons completely unrelated to
being exposed to the virus in our
building
unfortunately there's 35 guys now on the
covet 19 reserve list due to exposures
and infections they've sustained outside
of the building there's a point where
you just don't have enough players yeah
and that's my concern in the postseason
that we could get to that point yeah
that's what's scary and well what is and
what is that point you know where's the
line of demarcation there you think mike
i mean that's where i'm i'm interested
here you know and of course the nfl is
i'm sure a little nervous it's yeah it's
it's browns pittsburgh steelers this
weekend there's playoff intent you know
and intentions all all across the league
here and everything that's going on so
they don't want to reschedule and move
the whole playoffs do anything like that
no they can't right what can you do i
know exactly what can you do exactly
right i mean the only thing you could do
is you'd have to wait for it to end and
bump the playoffs back a week or
something like that and play this game
at some other point but of course no one
wants to do that in the nfl and they
shouldn't but i am interested in that
aspect of is that where that committee
comes into play
at some point that we talked about to
where we get to play off football and
what is the number right i mean it's 20
we're gonna just go yep you could still
play but we get the 30 and then the
team's gonna go hey are the nfl's gonna
go i don't know i mean i just i'm
interested to know what
you know they think is realistic or even
fair to a team to go out there and play
frankly i think that they don't give a
damn i think that as long as i think as
long as you got 11 guys they're going to
make you total 11. right they're going
to make you go i like it and and
that well because because at a certain
point and this is the argument that you
made way back when yeah even though guys
are getting it in the community there's
a certain point where the team must be
responsible for the fact
that their guys are not avoiding it in
the community right you still can't
avoid it right and if it is getting bad
in cleveland and and they said during
the conference call yesterday cleveland
right now is one of the areas where nfl
teams are located where it is as bad as
it's ever been well that's when you go
straight home into your hermetically
sealed room and you stay there until
it's time to emerge with a limited
interaction with anyone and then you go
back to work that's that's the the best
alternative to staying in a hotel and
we've heard limited talk about even a
voluntary playoff bubble they're
comfortable now with the idea of guys
going from facility to home facility to
home there's there's this paranoia i
think among the nfl
about putting everyone in a hotel
because if it somehow gets in then it's
an hour it ain't getting out right then
then then you're then then then how do
you avoid an outbreak if all the the
players and the coaches and everyone
else are confined to one hotel and it
somehow gets in there so they're hoping
this model works and yeah look i think
it's extreme to suggest that as long as
there are 11 players in uniform who can
play offense defense and special teams
for a full 60 minutes the legals say go
ahead and play but i i think that no
tiers will be shed for the team that
sees itself in this predicament where
that many guys have caught it away from
the facility because the nfl's attitude
is at some point it's on you to make
sure that your guys aren't catching it
away from work yeah i i well i think
that's the right way to do it i you know
i i get it you know and and you like
like like i said all along i think it's
the best way to keep some sort of
incentive for the players to
know that they got to be on their p's
and q's to to get their team to be
healthy and be able to play football you
know i mean if i'm if i'm a parent
player right now too and i'm going to
the playoffs like i'm telling my kids
like hey kids we're not going to school
this month we're going to do zoom calls
we're doing zoom you can go and join
your class that way whatever i'd be very
worried about this time of the year if i
was a you know a drew brees or whatever
any big time quarterback that with a
family that would certainly be crossing
my mind right now uh but i think it is
the right approach i like it in some way
in a lot of ways mike i really do
because again if a baltimore ravens type
situation arose in the playoffs
you know it's not fair to everybody in
the playoffs if baltimore like you know
the supposed strength coach who avoided
all protocols he does that well okay
fine screw you baltimore you didn't care
about the playoffs and screw you you're
gonna lose this weekend and i think
that's the way it should be for for
waiting for right now
i think a forfeit a much more likely
outcome in the postseason than in the
regular season really because in the
regular season again that idea of a
forfeit chris had had business
complications because the nfl failed to
negotiate the agreement with the nfl pa
to allow for players not to be paid in
the event of a forfeit they didn't want
to go there because they knew that based
on how everything was written and
negotiated there was a good chance they
were going to have to pay it's a
different deal altogether i think in the
post season and yeah what are you going
to do you can't stop the entire playoffs
because one team did something
ridiculously stupid and isn't able to
play i'm not saying it would happen but
i'm saying there's a greater likelihood
because it is much harder to move around
games when you're talking about everyone
playing at once and then moving on to
the next round where the winners play
we'll be talking
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports